I’m trying to quit cold turkey.
Hey there meat wads, Julian here for DNews.
For many of us in the United States, Thanksgiving
means putting up with our relatives long enough
to grab some of that sweet, sweet turkey and
honey glazed ham.
But for someone who has dietary restrictions
or objections to eating animals, even that
simple holiday pleasure is denied.
Unless of course, they replace it with a turkey
made of tofu (a tofurky) or a ham made of
some sort of meat analogue (a hamalogue).
On a nutritional level though, do these meat
substitutes have the chops to replace the
real thing?
It’s hard to pin down exactly how healthy
meat analogues are because there are quite
a few ways to skin a cat… or cow… or tofurkey.
There’s risofu made of rice, tempeh made
of soy, and a wheat-gluten product called
seitan, so yes, some vegetarian dishes are
literally the spawn of seitan.
But the one most familiar to non-vegetarians
is tofu, made from coagulated soy milk that’s
pressed into blocks.
For nutritional value, tofu and meat can trade
punches all day long.
Meat is the muscle tissue of an animal and
contains a lot more protein than tofu.
According to the United States Department
of Agriculture, gram for gram 80% lean ground
beef has more than double the protein of tofu,
while chicken contains over triple the protein.
On the other hand, both those meats have nearly
triple the fat as tofu, and processed meats
like sausage have way more fat, sometimes
even more fat than protein.
Plus tofu’s fat is mostly unsaturated, which
is better for lowering cholesterol.
Your body can happily use tofu to make proteins
because tofu contains the 9 essential amino
acids you can’t make on your own, but there
are some things faux meat can’t do as well
as the real thing.
For instance, tofu is higher in iron than
chicken, but the iron in chicken and other
meat is bundled up in heme, aka the red pigment
in your blood that binds to oxygen and gives
hemoglobin its name.
I think it goes without saying that plants
don’t have blood, so the iron in tofu is
nonheme and isn’t as easily used.
To get the most iron out of non-meat sources,
it’s necessary to supplement them with vitamin
C, which combines with the iron in a form
your body more readily absorbs.
Speaking of vitamins, a meat-free diet makes
it really difficult to get enough vitamin
B12, so if you’re eating tofurky or the
Ham of Seitan you’ll need a way to supplement
it.
A B12 deficiency can have a host of symptoms
like tiredness, numbness, tingling, vision
loss, constipation, and diarrhea (though obviously
not at the same time for those last two).
A vegetarian won’t necessarily have to worry
about that because B12 is still present in
eggs and dairy products but vegans eat absolutely
no animal products.
There are dairy substitutes like soy or almond
milk but they’re still missing that essential
vitamin unless they’re fortified with it.
As long as they’re careful about filling
in the gaps of a meat-free diet, vegetarians
and vegans should be able to feast with their
carnivorous relatives and still have a balanced
diet.
One day though, there may be meat that’s
completely cruelty free because it was grown
in a petri dish, eliminating the need for
the president to pardon a turkey ever again.
Now whether or not vegetarians and vegans
will accept these meat clones because of their
“unnatural” nature is another matter altogether.
So you're body can get along just fine without
the real meat but your tastebuds know the
difference.
Unless we can trick them!
To find out more about meatless meat, check
out Seeker Stories video right there.
Have you tried the faux fowl or would you
rather talk and eat real turkey?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for
more and I will see you all next time on DNews.
Happy Thanksgiving!